mr james bowman is the film and culture
critic for the american spectator
and the medium media columnist for the
new criterion
he also writes a weekly column on the
media for the epoch times
a graduate of lebanon valley college in
pennsylvania and cambridge university
he is a resident scholar at the ethics
and public policy center
in washington dc he previously taught
english and general studies in london
and portsmouth england for nine years
he returned to the united states as
america correspondent for the spectator
and later served as the american editor
of the times literary supplement
he is the author of honor a history and
media madness
the corruption of our political culture
please welcome james bowman
[Applause]
there's no knowing for sure of course
i may be wrong but i doubt that jane
austen
would have quite approved of the movies
we know from penny gays jane austen in
the theater
that she was a keen theater goer
whenever she had the chance
and was even quite undiscriminating in
her taste which ranged from
edmond keene's [ __ ] in drury lane in
1814
to the lurid melodramas of which we find
several parodies
among her juvenilia
but there isn't always has been a
titillating voyeuristic quality to the
movies
a sense of the camera's inevitable
intrusion into personal and domestic
privacy
that must have made moving pictures more
like the amateur dramatics and amateur
actors
of which we know from their treatment in
mansfield park
that she disapproved there in arguing
against the amateur performance
of lover's vows a play about
extramarital sex and illegitimacy
edmund bertram pleads against his
brother tom's contention that their
absent father would approve of it
because he approved of their declining
shakespeare when they were boys
my father wished us their school boys to
speak well says edmund
but he would never wish his grown-up
daughters to be acting plays
his sense of decorum is strict
so was jane austen's sense of decorum
strict
like that of her alter ego fanny price
in the novel who adamantly refuses to
take part in the play
lionel trilling thought this had to do
with fannie's and probably also also her
creators
horror at the insincerity of anyone like
the temperamentally inclined
actor henry crawford who could relish
pretending to be someone he was not
it is the actor in him examples of which
we see off the stage as well as on
as when he imagines himself to be a
naval hero or a spellbinding preacher
that makes fannie mistrust him and of
course
females on the stage were widely and not
always wrongly suspected of unchastity
for as long as there had been
females on the english stage which was
for just over a century before
jane austen was born but i think there's
another reason why
she might not have approved of the
movies or of television
this lies in what i believe to be the
central paradox of
jane austen's novels it's certainly true
that she prized
sincerity my emma says mr knightley to
the eponymous hermann heroine of that
novel
does not everything serve to prove more
and more the beauty of truth
and sincerity in all our dealings with
each other
but there was another virtue that she
prized even more highly
and that from one point of view at least
is the very antithesis
of sincerity and that is the virtue of
what she calls
self-command oh that my dear mother had
more command over herself
laments jane bennett in pride and
prejudice when her dear mother keeps
giving her painful reminders
of her having been forsaken as she
supposes by mr bingley
self-command was particularly important
for women because the inability
to suppress her feelings of regard or
attachment for a man at least until he
was prepared to offer her has his hand
and fortune in marriage
was likely to lead a woman into
unchastity and consequent ruin
as it does mariah bertram in mansfield
park
and isabella thorpe in northanger abbey
and almost does marianne dashwood in
sense and sensibility and lydia
in pride and prejudice it may seem hard
for us
us to reconcile such suppression of
one's feelings with the truth and
sincerity
in all our dealings recommended by mr
nightly
but i don't think it was hard for jane
austen or her contemporaries
our first requirement for appreciating
her therefore either on the page or on
the screen
is for ourselves to try to understand
the importance
for the kind of moral seriousness of
which jane austen is always an advocate
of what we would nowadays call the
repression
of powerful emotion
the first time i was asked to compare
the various cinematic or television
versions of her works was in the
millennium year of 2000 before many of
you were born
and was at the request of something
called the independent women's quarterly
a publication now no longer in existence
i'm sorry to say
of the screen versions of her novels
then existing i chose the 1993
adaptation of sense and sensibility
written by emma thompson and directed by
ang lee as the best
you'll have a chance to see it on
tuesday and i think i can promise you a
treat in store
if you haven't seen it including fine
performances by kate winslet as
marianne dashwood the late alan rickman
as colonel brandon
imelda stone as mrs palmer you laurie as
mr palmer
imogen stubs as lucy steele and greg
wise as
willoughby even hugh grant as edward
farrers who you would think would be all
wrong for the part
manages to make the blockish edward
almost plausibly lovable by poor eleanor
who is played by emma thompson herself
and it was her performance
the more than anyone else's which was
the making of the film in my opinion
her heroic self-command in the face of
the twin calamities of her sister's
indiscretions with willoughby
and lucy steele's entrusting her with
the unrevealable secret that the man she
loves
is engaged to another literally keeps
her family together
and it is rewarded at the end in a scene
which as i wrote at the time
it is impossible to watch unmoved when a
diffident po-faced edward reveals that
he is not as everyone had supposed
married to lucy steele
didn't she know that lucy had married
his brother instead
didn't everyone know it at this point
they hear the two
impassive eleanor rigid with
self-command suddenly
bursts into convulsive sobs
that continue as her mother and sisters
leave the room
leaving edward and his long despaired of
proposals
with eleanor the whole movie
the whole struggle between eleanor's
sense and marianne's sensibility
the whole of jane austen in a way is
present in that moment of
epiphany when self-command like a dam
breaking finally gives way
because it can give way to the pent-up
emotion behind it
i remember reading somewhere alas i
cannot remember where
that in dane austin's day the english
were looked on by the rest of europe the
way the italians were later to be
as typically emotionally incontinent
wearing their hearts on their sleeves as
my father used to call it
and unashamed to weep in public it was
supposedly only in the victorian era
that the famous british st
stiff upper lip came into being
especially for men
and the ability to suppress one's
feelings became a marker of manhood as
well as polytechnic
i'm not sure that this is true at the
first meeting in several months of the
brothers nightly in emma
we read that how do you do george and
john how are you
succeeded in the true english style
burying under a calmness that seemed all
but indifference
the real attachment which would have led
either of them if requisite
to do everything for the good of the
other
self-command is as important for men as
for women in other words
as a mark of good breeding and good
manners you may have noticed something
of this kind
of emotional restraint which was still
typical of the english within living
memory
in the version of pride and prejudice
that was shown here this afternoon
and which was made during the second
world war when british upper lips
had to be at their stiffest the film's
emotional reticence is particularly
noticeable if you compare it with such
more recent versions
as the 1995 six-part bbc adaptation by
andrew davis
or the feature film of ten years later
by joe wright with kieran knightley
as a feisty post-feminist elizabeth
bennett and matthew mcfadyen
as a lumbexy hang dog darcy
lawrence olivier the darcy in the 1940
version of
pride and prejudice was thought at the
time to represent something of a break
with the old
declamatory style of acting more
appropriate to the stage
in favor of a more realistic manner
demanded by the movies
but his darcy seems to me to be an
example not so much of emotional
suppression as of emotional
absence more generally the film skates
over all the novels
emotional depths as we have since
learned to see them
and treats it instead is nothing but a
rollicking comedy of manners
something also evident in the extreme
liberties that the hollywood of that
period
took with the text the most shocking of
which
in my view is it's making the visit of
cat lady catherine de borg
edna mae oliver to greer garson's
elizabeth on the eve of her engagement
to darcy as a put up job between the old
lady and her nephew
to test the younger woman for any
mercenary motive she might have in
accepting him
this doesn't even make sense from the
point of view of the plot since her
earlier refusal of darcy's proposal
should have put to rest any suspicions
of that sort
my own suspicion is that the
screenwriter aldous huxley
raised in stiff upper lip britain and
working on a dramatization of the novel
by the australian
transplant helen jerome simply took its
theme of emotional restraint and reserve
for granted
the same is true though to a lesser
extent if you go back and look at the
bbc's
adaptations of persuasion and emma from
1971 and 1972 respectively
in which the staginess of early
television drama
especially in such period pieces or
costume dramas such as these
combined with what one can only supposed
to be the congenital stiffness of the
actors
make them almost unwatchable by present
day standards
though they do have the virtue of
including more if it is a virtue
including more of the text than most
versions
yet in their stiffness and formality of
manner and apparent lack of feeling
these 1970s versions of jane austen must
be closer to the way she herself would
have
envisioned envisaged her characters than
later versions
the more important way in which they go
astray in my opinion is that they treat
the novels as being
satirical in a way that jane austen was
not or not in the senses we
now understand the term in other words
they see her as a satirist
of social class distinctions and
snobbery things that were of greater
concern in the last century than they
were in jane austen's time more than
they are now
now that our political attention has
turned to more
interesting classes of the
self-identified oppressed
than those who merely lack leisure
social prestige
or money but jane austen i think has no
political access to grind
she takes distinctions of social class
for granted and it would never occur to
her to ridicule others who do the same
though some may give too much importance
to social standing like lady russell in
persuasion
of whom it is said that she had a value
for rank and consequence which blinded
her a little to the faults of those who
possess them
coryn redgrave of the socialist workers
party and the famously radical redgrave
family
hamming it up as the snobbish sir walter
elliott in the 1995 persuasion
so much so that he's almost allowed to
overshadow the love story of ann
and captain wentworth may have been the
last gasp of this mid-century view of
jane austen
as social satirist but the sudden spate
of cinematic adaptions of her novels in
the 1990s and after the 20th centuries
after the 20th century's obsession with
social class had largely spent itself
was the result i believe of a renewed
interest in jane austen the moralist
which is also how she was seen in her
own time this is important because
there's never been a time in the
english-speaking world when we've been
more in need of moral guidance
now that we have a new ideologically
based morality
every day further displacing the
traditional kind
the jane austen kind and assuming
cultural dominance over us
the linguist and social philosopher john
mcquarter does not scruple to call this
so-called
woke consciousness a new religion
i would prefer to call it an ideology
and the intellectual attraction of
ideology unlike that of the religion
which as you may remember used to tell
us that we were all sinners
is that if you only believe you can
never be wrong
the ideologue will allow you to speak of
yourself as being on the right side of
history
because you may assume that you already
know how history will come out
your ideology informs you of this in
advance and you can use your supposed
knowledge of your support your supposed
rightness about everything
to shame those who are still among the
doubters you can tell them as the actor
sean penn did at the
oscars a few years ago that their
grandchildren will be ashamed of them
for having resisted the tide of moral
certainty
that must certainly carry all before it
into the future
in other words our ideologically
dominated society is as morally
primitive
as it is scientifically advanced
even non-ideologues tend to take the
view as who would not
who had never been told that there was
anything to stop them that both
morality and science are all about
being right when they both are much much
more about being wrong
we put all our morality like our science
around us as if they were a cloak of
invulnerability
for our opinions when properly
understood both
are instead the instruments of those
opinions dissections
and very often destruction
some years ago the journalist catherine
schultz wrote a book called being wrong
adventures in the margin of error in
which she invented a new
science of wrongology
i recommend it to you as one of the most
important books of our century
but jane austen was there ahead of her
as i see them and i as i hope you will
her novels all focus on a moral moment
that can only be called
dramatic which is why they adapt so well
to the screen
in our time and why they have taken on a
new relevance and cogency to so many in
the very very different world of two
centuries later
this is what i call the i was wrong
moment
all of her heroines and most of her
heroes have to suffer through the
mortification of an i was wrong moment
fanny price and ann elliott are partial
exceptions but only partial
although fannie is never far from
self-doubt she is also she is only ever
wrong about being wrong
which is to say she's wrong about her
occasional doubtful i was wrong moments
and write about the crawfords when
everyone else is telling her she's wrong
she's right too about maria mariah and
julia's faults of immodesty and write
about who edmund really loves
though she tries hardest to talk herself
into being wrong about this
it is edmund who has to pass through the
i was wrong fire most scorchingly
and that i think robs this novel is some
of the poignancy of the others wherein
female wrongness seems to me by contrast
to carry with it the conviction of
personal
experience
and elliot's i was wrong moment takes
place
before the action of the novel begins
when she realizes that she was wrong to
have yielded to lady russell's
persuasion in breaking off her
engagement
to captain wentworth which means that it
is wentworth who experiences
persuasion's main i was wrong moment in
realizing after louisa musgrove's
accident that the firmness of purpose
which louisa has and anne is supposed to
lack is not after all
and unleavened by prudence the most
desirable quality in a woman
and that it is only his own pride which
has kept him from returning to his first
love
here as in mansfield park the main i was
wrong moments being predicated of
her principal male characters makes the
dramatizations
of both novels compared with the others
less successful in my view
perhaps because it's less unexpected
when a man turns out to be wrong
or at least when he admits to it
this may also be why patricia patricia
rosema in her 1999 version of mansfield
park felt she had to jazz up jane with a
completely gratuitous polemic against
slavery
on sir thomas bertram's plantations in
antigua
something about which her fanny played
by francis o'connor
obviously finds it as easy to be right
as we do in retrospect
and the same goes for the many little
feminist applause lines that even the
best of the movie and tv adaptations
can't resist adding
occasionally to the original i've
already mentioned the mistake as i see
it in the 1995 version of persuasions
implied self-congratulation by
concentrating too much on the obvious
but never acknowledged wrongness of sir
walter
as opposed to the less obvious but more
painfully realized wrongness of captain
wentworth
so walter is just one of the many
characters in the novels who serve
as a foil or as foils to the i was wrong
characters by being like
today's ideologues incapable of seeing
themselves in the wrong no matter how
wrong they are
not all these characters are villains
like sir walter or general tilney or
william elliot or the crawford's
some only come in for more or less
gentle ridicule like mr collins or mrs
elton
or mrs bennett but what they all have in
common
is self-assurance self-assurance is
self-command
but without that other great austenian
virtue of
self-knowledge unaware of itself
self-assurance takes its own mannerly
insincerity for the warmest sympathy
or even as in henry crawford's case love
therefore it is immune to the self-doubt
that is the trial through which
all jane austen's heroines have to pass
nowadays we might call such
self-assurance cool
henry crawford is certainly a very cool
guy
so is mr william elliott in persuasion
john thorpe of northanger abbey is a
mere buffoon
like so many oxford men trying
trying without success to be a cool guy
but all of them share what jane austen
herself most often refers to as
self-conceit
or vanity not that is sir walters kind
of personal
vanity of personal appearance so much as
that which she attributes to henry
crawford
when he is said to have had all the
disposition to persevere that sir thomas
could wish him
he had vanity which strongly inclined
him in the first place to think that
fannie did love him
although she might not know it herself
this kind of vanity is the salient
characteristic of all her villains
and her objects of ridicule both in the
in the cool both the cool and the uncool
like mr collins in pride and prejudice
or mr elton
elton and emma the two latter being
clergyman interestingly rather than
actors
frank churchill of emma is also a very
cool guy
and so as mr nightly points out not to
be trusted
but he escapes absolute villainy by
sufficient self-knowledge to be always
aware of his putting on an act and of
having a very
particular object in doing so and also
by knowing even as he does so
that putting on an act is wrong he's
maybe the only character in the jane
austen corpus who is both culpably
self-assured
and capable of a sincerely penitential i
was wrong moment
of at least partial self-redemption
darcy might be another candidate except
that his self-assurance is less culpable
and less calculating
and his confession of error more sincere
willoughby in sense and sensibility
isn't as a
an interesting case in this respect in a
scene
which was for unknown reason for for not
understandable for understandable
reasons cut from the from the movie
uh we we see him uh appearing before
eleanor
penitent about his treatment of marianne
and pleading with her for a measure of
forgiveness
this scene is obviously meant to be
taken sincere
as sincere on his part but he has not
the self-knowledge
of claudius and hamlet who in his
penitential
scene asks himself may one be pardoned
and retain the offence
he is unfortunately still possessed of
those effects
a rich wife and an end to indebtedness
as well as a reconciliation with his
aunt for which he did
he jilted marianne his regret
what he had to had to give up for them
having been insufficient to prevent him
from taking the
the moral course has become something he
will have to live with for the rest of
his life
the crime as eleanor observes carries
with its own punishment
all this the movie reduces to a single
shot at the very end of willoughby all
alone on horseback looking sadly down
from a nearby hill on the scene of a
double of the double wedding
just as self-assurance is characteristic
of all the bad or ridiculous people in
her novel so his self-doubt and
self-correction characteristic of all
her heroes and
especially her heroines her portrayal of
her unenduring instinct for what the
greeks called the peripatea
or reversal in the dramatic i was wrong
moment is what makes for novels all as
well
as well as the best of the movies or
mini series based on them
peculiarly relevant to our time
i think it's no coincidence that the two
most often and most successfully adapted
novels
pride and prejudice and emma are also
the two with the most and the most
affecting
i was wrong moments the final chapters
of pride and prejudice are a positive
riot of wrongness
beginning with jane's being wrong about
bingley's continuing and constant regard
for her and bingley's being wrong about
her lack of same for him
but this is nothing next to elizabeth's
constantly trying to talk herself into
being wrong for the second time but in
the opposite direction
about darcy's feelings for her until she
discovers that she was wrong about being
wrong
from darcy's confession to her about all
the ways he was wrong until she herself
put him right
then when both daughters and their
fiancees have sorted the right from the
wrong they have to put their family
father and mother sisters right about
the ways they have been wrong about
lizzi's supposed hatred of darcy
all this without mentioning the
superlative wrongness of catherine
bingley or caroline wingley sorry
lady catherine deboer and mr collins
none of whom has the capacity to
recognize his or her own wrongness
not a character escapes the pitfalls of
wrongness of one sort or another except
perhaps for charlotte lucas who is
presumed to have gone into her marriage
with mr collins with her eyes open
to his many and varied wrongnesses and
closed to them thereafter
and all the characters are defined for
us by their reaction to being wrong
even when as in the cases of mrs bennett
lydia and wickham they can never begot
to acknowledge it
mrs bennett simply ignores her own
mistakes when they are revealed to her
and assume she's always thought of
bingley and darcy as she does now
in this she is like mrs allen in
northanger abbey and mr weston and emma
both of whom keep saying i knew it would
be so when everything they had said
would
said would be so turns out to be wrong
mr bennett is a particularly interesting
case in this respect as he is unusually
ready to admit to being wrong
but at the same time feels it less or
less lastingly than anyone else in the
novel
with that capacity and confessing to his
own fault in the laxity of parental
control which has resulted in lydia's
eloquent with wickham
he says to elizabeth who should suffer
but myself
it has been my own doing and i ought to
feel it
you must not be too severe upon yourself
lizzy replies
you may well warn me against such an
evil he says human nature is so prone to
fall into it
no lizzie let me once in my life feel
how much i've been to blame
i'm not afraid of being overpowered by
the impression it will pass away soon
enough
the comedy of interlacing wrongnesses in
these final chapters and the almost
farcical quality of our delight in miss
austin's
unraveling of them to make everything
turn out incredibly right
must be why this has always been the
most popular of her novels and why
its various adaptations have been on the
whole the most successful
the best of these has still got to be
that 1995 bbc version
in six parts with colin firth as darcy
and jennifer ailey as
elizabeth not to mention the great
allison stedman as the mrs bennett to me
and all mrs bennett
but the connoisseur of wrongness which i
hope you are all beginning to be by now
must always have a special place in his
heart for emma
since emma woodhouse is by far the
wrongest of all her heroines
more wrong even than the hopelessly
naive and four years younger catherine
moorland in northanger abbey
at least half of whose wrongness passes
unnoticed by her
and remains a private joke between the
author and her readers
emma hasn't catherine's excuse for going
wrong which may be why jane austen
thought that nobody would like much like
her but herself
the number of adaptations of the novel
in recent years suggests that she was
wrong about this
but is that because we like her is it do
we like her because or in spite of her
rumors numerous errors
let's try to count them up
first as mr knightley points out to her
in chapter one
she's wrong to think that she has
arranged the match between mr weston and
miss taylor
then she's wrong about harriet and
robert martin wrong about harriet and mr
elton
wrong about harriet and frank churchill
wrong finally about harriet and mr
nightly
and each of these major errors comprises
numerous lesser ones
like all those instances of which she is
so eager to mistake mr elton's
little attentions to harriet before her
eyes are opened as to their real object
and then there her are her mistakes
about frank churchill and herself about
jane
fairfax and mr dixon jane fairfax and
the mysterious president of the piano
forte and most momentously
but like everybody else in highbury her
being wrong about jane and frank
churchill
part of what leads her to be wrong in
her insult to miss bates
the mistake also pointed out to her by
mr nightly
his and the westerns being wrong about
her and frank churchill appears a mere
trifle next to the number of emma's
wrong thoughts and deeds every one of
which she has to face up to sooner or
later
though her final mistake about mr
nightly's feelings for her
are as happily wrong as lizzie bennett's
about mr darcy's feelings for her
actually there is one species of error
that she's not shown is facing up to
though it may be that we are meant to
understand she does
as it takes place in private perhaps her
self-correction is allowed to take place
off the page but when she rages to
herself about mr elton's misdirected
proposal
she abuses him to herself for exactly
the fault of aspiring to rise above his
social
level that he had abused that that that
he had abused harriet smith for
so much to her annoyance this in turn
reminds us of her snobbery towards mr
martin though it does not
so remind her she still thinks she was
right to break off that match
the failure here is one of
self-awareness of not being able to see
when she's blaming others for her own
faults
the dawning of self-awareness is the
rarest and most spiritually significant
of all
i was wrong moments but in emma it takes
its most benign form
when after harriet confesses what she
takes to be wrongly of course
an attachment to mr nightly it darted
through her with the speed of an arrow
that mr knightley must marry no one but
herself
here at last we are told is the
beginning of that knowledge of herself
that can only come with a recognition
that she has been
quote totally ignorant of her own heart
so which is the best screen version of
emma
there is much to be said for gwyneth
paltrow's emma in douglas
douglas mcgrath movie of 1996 which you
will
you may see tomorrow but it goes badly
wrong itself in taking one of emma's
wrong
wrongnesses away from her and giving it
to frank churchill instead
this is the suspicion about jane fairfax
and mr dixon which
in his in this version is is um
proposed by frank instead of being
emma's
surmise which is uh out of her natural
love of
intrigue in other words it's a lie
the more seriously miss paltrow as i was
wrong moments are
almost as anodyne as those of her alter
ego and amy heckerling's clueless
which came out at about the same time
there the emma character called
cher and played by an alicia silverstone
makes only comic errors while her very
brief i was wrong moment is sued the way
and rendered unimportant by the
emollient words of a very implausible mr
nightly
character played by the young paul rudd
mrs paltrow's emma may say that she is
wrong but we never really see anything
that looks very much like a dart
of self-knowledge hitting her with the
speed of an error
on the plus side ewan mcgregor makes a
very plausibly caddish frank churchill
alan [ __ ] is the most comically
concious of all possible mr eltons and
jeremy northam the most mr nightly like
mr knightley
that i have seen tony colette is in some
ways the more
most interesting harriet too but she's
too much over the top like an embryo mrs
bennett
and not a plausible love interest for
any of the suitors to whom emma
would assign her or even the allegedly
sensible robert martin
the most beautiful as harriet is
described in the novel
as well as the most charmingly dim
harriet i have seen is louise dillon in
the 2009 bbc miniseries which
also has by far the best mr woodhouse
and michael gambon
and a very decent emma and knightley in
romelu garai and johnny lee miller
like all miniseries it also has rooms to
squeeze in far more of the novel and all
its riches
than a feature film can do
as for the last year's film of emma
directed by autumn de wilder
i hated almost everything about it
beginning with the wide-eyed game-like
almost
baby-doll look of anya taylor joy's emma
indeed i hated the looks of all the main
characters except for miranda hearts
miss bates who was perhaps the best in
that role i've seen
i also hated the way bill nye's mr
woodhouse enters leaping
as if to stick a thumb in the eye of
every other portrayal of him as a
valitudinarian as in
you know the novel
i hated the way the supposedly manly mr
knightley aged 37 played by 37 year old
johnny flynn
acts like a lovesick teenager pumping
his fist in the air and showing his
apparent lack of self-command
in every emotion he openly feels not at
all in other words in the
true english style as described by jane
austen
i hated the self-conscious exaggeration
of every comic effect
and the obtrusive musical pointing with
a jumble of irish sounding folk music
choral church music and bits of haydn
mozart and beethoven
but when it comes to the wrongology of
emma's various self-epiphanies
especially when she responds to mr
nightly's proposal
with the look of one absolutely polaxed
with dawning self-awareness
her almost comically wide set eyes
finally coming into their own
moreover a spontaneous nose bleed on the
occasion
seems no more than an appropriate
reminder of the wounding
and death and rebirth that the
penitential process
mimics not to mention the arrow of
self-awareness
darting through her as mentioned earlier
this the greatest of the cinematic i was
wrong moments
is good enough to make me think that all
those other things that i disliked about
the movie
might be deliberate exercises in
wrongology themselves
there's no doubt at any rate that i too
can be wrong
thank you
thank you mr bowman we now have time for
some q a
if you have a question please make your
way to the microphones
um
thank you thank you very much that was
really
um that was a wonderful talk i just was
really intrigued by what you mentioned
at the end
um i'm sorry is this better that's
better thank you
thank you um i have not seen all of the
new emma
movie but i was not a fan of it just
because it
it didn't seem it seemed to be you know
making fun of the book
but i was intrigued by what you said
that maybe it was all just following the
wrongness ideology
it was all what um that maybe that was
just
the wrongness ideology maybe wrongology
sorry the wrongology that maybe all of
those other seeming
seemingly errors were just part of that
wrongology so i was wondering if you
could expand a little bit on that
well when when somebody does something
so right
you kind of look back and think of all
the other things that they've done wrong
in a different light
it seems it seems to me um i
i just um
i i needed to see it again obviously
after
after that ending because i thought well
if she does this right then maybe she
was doing the other things right that i
thought she was doing wrong
maybe she could only have produced this
brilliant effect at the end
by doing all the other things wrong that
i thought you did wrong
hi thank you i really enjoyed that
lecture um at the beginning you
said something along the lines of jane
austen
taking the social classes for granted in
her stories and i was wondering if you
could expand a little bit more on what
you
meant by that statement
um well they were a fact of life
um this social gradations um
there's a in the um 2007 version of
pride and prejudice there is um
there is some temp some attempt uh i
think it's two thousand is it two
thousand seven uh
anyway it's the one with karen knightley
um
and donald sutherland is a as a really
not very good
um mr bennett um but there was
there was a a lot of effort in that i
should have i should have um
should have mentioned that uh two cast
to turn the camera on the servants uh
and the and the
the lower the lower class people who are
taken for granted in
in most of most versions of of jane
austen
um as a reminder uh that these these
people live the way they live
because of the labors of people that
they look down on
um that's a that's a very modern way of
of looking at it um and it's not i i
think
you know as best i can tell it's not
jane austen's way
um she too would take the servants for
granted
um she too would recognize it
every as mr helton says everyone has
their level
um that you it was a serious matter if
you
if you married too far up or down from
the class you were born into
um because it it involved your family
and that's that's the point mr darcy
was making about about jane about
lizzie's family um it uh
it was it was a real consideration and i
think it one that jane austen would have
would have shared as she would
most of the things that seem to us in
our egalitarian age
a much more uh worrisome thing as i say
though i think we're
kind of getting away from that a little
bit it's more of a 20th century
obsession this idea with social classes
now we have other classes that
we care more about you know race sex
sexual orientation all that sort of
thing is more more important to us than
social hierarchies
um hi um so at the very beginning
you talked about austin loving theater
um
but kind of hating those amateur plays
that
can be just kind of base and so i was
just wondering if you could speak a
little bit about how she writes these
books that are these moral books
but then they always have this kind of
romantic or at least who's going to
marry who aspect to them
and so kind of why that is a big part of
it
when she's writing such books about
morality
when she's writing books about morality
well for a woman that was
the supreme area of morality that
that was the morality that that mattered
for women more than anything else
because
marriage mattered for them more than
anything else it was the only way
they could escape from i mean if women
of this
of the class that jane austen is
concerned was the only way they could
could hope to leave their father's house
and move to a husband's house
you couldn't just go out on your own in
those days and and so
marriage and all that surrounds it
including
the the emotions um and
love uh which even then was
pretty important to people in in looking
for
marital partners um this
became the central concern of their
lives it's you know that's
that's what uh mrs bennett is all about
i mean she's a silly woman but she's
she's only doing what what any woman in
her
situation would would feel necessary to
do
this which is to get her daughters
married however she could because
actually that's the only way they could
ever be
independent of her
so morality for for a woman
basically concerned sex and marriage and
and that was that was pretty much it
yes so you mentioned that mr darcy had a
very sincere confession of error did you
find any other characters in the other
movies that had similar
uh sincerity moments i'm sorry i didn't
miss the beginning did you think that
any other characters
in the jane austen movies had moments of
sincerity similar to mr darcy's
confession of error oh yes yes i think
they
they all they all well all the good all
the good ones
they uh they were all sincere i think in
in confessing there i
i think there's there must be some doubt
about frank churchill
um uh uh
being totally sincere anyway uh
you know claiming to have known all
along that he was doing wrong but um
uh thinking that you know now that he's
got what he
wanted to by by doing it he can
apologize and everything will be okay
um but and i think in all the other
cases
um the uh the sincerity is
is pretty obvious um there are
other occasions when uh when
people confess to being wrong when they
when that when it isn't sincere i think
henry crawford is one
one example of that in in mansfield park
where
um where he says you know i'm
i'm wrong i'm i'm i know i'm wrong tell
me tell me what tell me what's right
to to katherine or to um fanny
um which is just
another way of his trying to get around
her get around her defenses you know
oh well this is what she wants well
that's what i'll do
but um mostly the i was wrong moment is
a
moment of sincerity i think i think
yes um okay sir i
i thought a point you made was very
interesting about how
jade this element in jane austen's
novels about
the characters being wrong and realizing
their wrongness
is one of the elements that makes them
good stories
yeah and then you brought up some other
the film adaptions that did not address
that and kind of skirted over the issue
of the characters being wrong and them
realizing
so do you think that and these these
were the worst adaptations
so do you think that in this
in this culture they they
purposely did not make the characters
address they're wrong like do you think
that's
some fear on the part of the filmmakers
of
admitting the fallibility of their
characters or just what are your
thoughts on that
no i think they they they just didn't
take it that seriously
um as you as you can if you compare
um if you compare the the the movie
that was shown this afternoon greer
garson's confession of
of error seems
almost gratuitous i mean partly that's
part because of the constraints of the
film that you know
one minute she's saying i hate you the
next minute she's saying i love him
you know what happened it's uh it
can't all be down to just that uh you
know getting put right about what it was
wickham um but
uh it's it's just it's
passed over because i think partly
because mainly because
um it was conceived of as a comedy it
was
you know we know we don't want the
laughing to stop we don't want to get
too serious here
we don't want to say oh my god i was
wrong uh we managed to say oh
i was wrong you know and then we move on
to the next funny
funny episode it's uh i think it's it's
you know it's a way of looking at a
different
looking at it dramatically from a
different from a different point of view
as they did back in 1940 and as
as i think now we're more inclined to do
it it's more to see
it's it's a more serious business when
when we're
when we're wrong and and we can
understand i think we can understand it
more maybe they were just more used to
being wrong back in those days
hi there um thanks for your lecture it
was really really good
um the 1995 pride and prejudice is
objectively the best so
the 1995 pride and prejudice is
objectively the best so yes yes
i agree so i uh i really like what you
were saying about um
the kind of tension between self
knowledge
and what was the other it was um
self demand i think so self command yes
yeah and i was just wondering what
insights you think jane austen had
as to
those those two virtues i suppose
um did she have a sense of
which one was more commonly uh
difficult for a man to achieve or which
one was more difficult for a woman to
achieve or or is it just kind of case by
case basis
like is is the virtue um
are these virtues sometimes more
masculine and easier for men to
achieve i mean i mean i think that darcy
seems to have
some appearance of self-command but no
self-knowledge but then you could even
argue that he
doesn't have self-command because he
can't really show who he really
is no that's
showing who you really are is not a good
thing in in jail
but i think you're right to say that
it's it's more it's easy
easier to assume it of a man than of a
woman
um for for jane austen i i
i hesitate or i hasten to add
um that uh
partly because it's a it's an
ideological thing this is the point of
um
of uh sense and sensibility that
marianne is a spokesman for a
our spokeswoman for a new way
of looking at emotion it's it was called
sensibility and it was a sort of
movement of the romantic period and
she's a very romantic
woman who thought that people ought to
show their feelings you know that this
is
it's a bad thing to repress them it's
the beginnings of
of our our more modern way of looking at
things
and jane austen is standing pretty
firmly against that
and saying you know this is what happens
this is what happens when you do that
when you
when you let your let your feelings show
show who you really are don't do that
no particularly if you're a woman
it's all kinds of trouble
yes oh okay so i was wondering
um what are your thoughts on that idea
of wrongness
in lady susan i mean because that's
one of the only novels
that has someone who is
that wrong yeah
yeah you're right um uh and that's uh
that's sort of why i didn't mention lady
susan because
it completely overthrows everything i
said no
no um it's i
i see lady susan as apprentice work uh
basically she's she's learning her trade
when she when she wrote that
um and she she did
i think she frankly delighted in someone
as wicked as
lady susan vernon uh and she just
she just enjoyed that creation she
wasn't
she wasn't really in in her moralistic
vein at that
at that stage she was just uh just
playing around with
the idea of someone who could be that
calculating in that
wicked um and showing it in sort of the
indirect way through the
epistolary style um
it it is but you're right it is a it's
certainly
uh unusual in the in the whole corpus
he never wrote like that away again
okay this is our last question sure
hello thank you that was great uh thank
you mr bowman
you you spoke of uh jane austen as a
moralist and the moralist we need
um but there's moralism and there's
moralism right
and uh with genocide
i just mean there's there's certain
kinds of moralism that you don't want to
sit through
um but you don't really feel jane
austen's moralism
as uh as a burden
i guess that's what a burden uh it's
it's a burden yes you don't feel it that
oh yes i don't know
what i'm saying is why do we like why do
we like jane austen's moralism and not
feel it as sharmonic or something
well whereas there are many other many
other kinds of films and novels
that we don't have patients with that
are trying to do something similar
that's a good question um
well i i i think it's because
um she's so obviously sincere
uh she's so obviously engaged with these
these very serious moral issues and not
just preaching
she's she's showing him an action she's
showing showing how people actually
make decisions good and bad and how they
get things wrong
um and and showing it in a way that it's
sympathetic she
she understands how their minds are
working she understands what's going on
she she's not you know laying down the
law and saying oh you know isn't this
terrible
she's she's just showing us she's just
showing it how how it works and
and we recognize that because we we've
had
similar experiences ourselves most of it
um
and uh so it's it's not preachy
as you say it's a there's a there's a
great line in the
in pride and prejudice about mary the
the the serious
daughter who's all engaged in
philosophical studies and
all that about her threadbare moralism
you know um
she's she's the one that always has a
platitude ready for
every occasion you know but ah this is
wrong and this is right
um but you know but nobody pays any
attention to her because it's it's just
words it's just a
it's just preaching um whereas
what jane austen is doing is is showing
us the thing in action and
that we can all relate to i think
thank you
you